munster in niedersachsen hier am größten
heeres standort leben fast nur soldaten
und der spd chef lars klingbeil klingt
erst mal langweilig aber moment bevor
sie abschalten wir haben lustige puppen
dabei wir reden heute über die
bundeswehr das kann auch mal ein
bisschen trocken sein vom thema deswegen
haben wir hier diese tröten und jedes
mal wenn wir das gefühl haben jetzt
hätten geld ganz gut gibt es ein fun
fact über die
bundeswehr würden sie dann sagen ist
schuld am aktuellen zustand der
bundeswehr und wer ist eigentlich schuld
an christine lambrecht das sind die
landrechte sind gut zu hören wir müssen
doch gut wenn sie geld machen herkriegen
weil wir haben ja das spiel auch erklärt
wie war das früher für sie also ich
meine monster sie sagen wir fahren auch
panzer herum für mich war es ja normal
damit auf zu wachsen also ich kannte das
andere erkannte mein vater auch soldat
ja dass morgens noch nicht vorm aus dem
haus gegangen damit dass in uniform da
und abends kann man die form wieder und
waren natürlich auch viel auf bundeswehr
veranstaltungen sie werden doch der
bessere verteidigungsminister ich bin
parteivorsitzender der spd das ist sehr
ausfüllen und macht mich sehr froh
glaube ich habe sie werden doch der
bessere ich habe mich ja bewusst
entschieden parteivorsitzende ist aber
sie werden
ich bin gerne pater versetzt
dann kam noch ein fun fact er laut der
wehrbeauftragte eva högl fehlt es den
soldaten sogar an warmer unterwäsche da
stimmt die wird privat teilweise bei
amazon bestellt das hat mir jemand jetzt
dass ein einsatz erzählt ich weiß gar
nicht welche einsetzt das war das dann
der pakete von amazon kommen ohne die
soldatinnen und soldaten sich privat
unterwäsche bestellen und das geht ja
weiter es geht auch in rucksäcken das
ist mit nachtsichtgeräten es gibt
soldatinnen und soldaten die bis zu 800
euro 1.000 euro privat für
material ausgeben wenn sie einen
auslandseinsatz gehen
mir war es ein bisschen zu ernst jetzt
wenn die bundeswehr den panzer puma an
einen anderen ort verlegen will muss sie
den panzer auseinanderbauen und den
zweit schadens zum zielort fliegen wo
sie ihn dann wieder zusammenbauen muss
weil bei der planung niemandem
aufgefallen ist dass der panzer puma zu
schwer für das transportflugzeug a400m
ist
wenn man transportflugzeug auf ne sollte
man ja darauf achten 50 zloty nahe
gesicht
lustiger fun fact oder erst sehr lustig
es ist sehr deprimierend wenn das
glücklich stimmen sollte und ich glaube
es ist jetzt einfach mal aber sie sind
auch der meinung dass sich das bild der
bundeswehr jetzt so massiv gewandelt hat
oder seitdem spätestens seitdem also
mein bild nicht aber das bild so
insgesamt in der bundeswehr ich glaube
das war nie wirklich schlecht bei der
mehrheit der menschen aber es war eine
gleichgültigkeit ich will ja keine
glorifizierung aber ich finde schon dass
man als bürger wie wir jetzt auch immer
anerkennen muss da sind menschen die
sind im zweifel zwar bereit ihr leben zu
geben für dieses land wenn ich mit
soldatinnen und soldaten rede die zum
beispiel erzählen dass sie mit der
uniform zugfahren dass sie beschimpft
werden sie beleidigt werden ja ich hab
ich kenne menschen die wurden bespuckt
und sowas darf nicht passieren in diesem
land ja vor allem weil bahnfahren ist ja
an sich schon seit jeher eben genau und
werden beim bespuckt wird und der
kombination noch zu spät zur
friedenspolitik gehört für sie ja auch
militärische gewalt als legitimes mittel
der politik was hätte ihn der zebras
dazu gesagt der hätte mir hat
widersprochen dabei wir werden bleibt
mir putin nicht überzeugen können indem
wir
indem wir jetzt nur gut auf ihn einreden
aber putin hat schon mehr für die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr getan als
jeder deutsche politiker eigentlich
putin ist schon der katalysator dafür
dass diese 100 milliarden euro auf den
weg kommen muss nicht drum herum reden
also wurde diesen krieg hätte es das
nicht gegeben
und das heißt ohne den krieg nur das
festhalten müssten die soldaten sich
weiter bei amazon unterwäsche bestellen
wir haben ja schon den verteidigungsetat
erhöht die letzten jahre aber das hat ja
oder nein also
wir haben schon systematisch daran
gearbeitet dass diese persönlichen
ausrüstung besser werden aber es hätte
sein können dass der zeitraum über den
man sich das bei amazon bestellt noch
ein bisschen länger ist es jetzt gerade
der fall sein wird zum beispiel hat ja
und finanzminister olaf scholz den
letzten jahren dafür gesorgt dass der
etat der bundeswehr erheblich
angestiegen ist und warum sorgt ein
kanzler oder falls jetzt nicht dafür
dass der auch dann weiter schreck stadt
fertig zu werden so dass sie haben ja
gerade 100 milliarden durch gesetz im
bundestag und tun jetzt ganz viel gut da
sollte man das richtig durchrechnet dann
fehlen jahr 2027 schon wieder 32
milliarden da muss denn von der nächsten
regierung nach wegen gesucht werden aber
die politische zielsetzung die zwei
prozent zu erreichen ist klar aber das
ist jetzt das ist der satz ist schon
gefallen es muss von der nähe die
regierung nach wegen gesucht werden das
erst mal dabei ist es gibt ja gibt ja
einen klaren beschluss des bundestags
und der muss ja erstmal seien wieder
gebrochen werden und da sehe ich keine
politische mehrheit für die das tut also
zum abschluss wird der absurdeste fakt
den wir gelesen haben der sirup noch
wollen sie auch mit hupen
christine lambrecht ist
verteidigungsministerin superfrau
quarnbek dankeschön man sollte man mit
einem gellenden danke
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]